CARTER MORGAN: In
2018, there were
over 16,000 vulnerabilities
published in public databases.
And that's just the
ones we know about.
But a program as simple
as Add A Cat To That
couldn't possibly have
one of those, right?
Right?
You know what?
Stick around.
Because we should probably
use Cloud Registry
Scanner to check on our software
supply chain, just in case.
Add A Cat To That is
a very short program,
no more than a
dozen lines of code
implement its core
functionality.
But believe it or
not, it has hundreds
of dependencies, each of which
expands our attack surface.
Using other people's
work made Add A Cat
To That easy to write, but
it's also a potential weakness.
Any one of those libraries could
be neglected or compromised.
And with so many of them,
it's next to impossible
to manually keep up with
the ever-growing list
of vulnerabilities.
What's a developer to do?
Fortunately, we're using
Google Container Registry
to store our container images.
It has a feature that can help
us secure our supply chain,
called Vulnerability Scanning.
Once we've enabled
this feature, we
can go back to
our list of images
and look under the
Vulnerabilities column.
And we can see that
our tiny little image
has over 600 vulnerabilities
and only 38 fixes.
We could dive into each
of these vulnerabilities
to see if we could fix them.
For example, let's click on
one of the ImageMagick issues
to find details on exactly
what the vulnerability is--
"an uninitialized variable
leading to memory corruption."
Now we could dig through
the variables use
cases to see if this
error is relevant to us.
And even if there's
not a fix, we
might be able to set up
some secondary measures
to protect ourselves.
But let's try a different way.
Looking through the
vulnerabilities list,
we notice that a lot of them
are related to ImageMagick.
So let's reduce
our attack surface
by swapping out ImageMagick
with the simpler Python
library, called Pillow.
We can also improve
our security posture
by choosing a
different base image.
We're currently
using Python 3.7,
which contains a lot of
dependencies we don't need.
And many of the
vulnerabilities we're seeing
are coming from that image.
We can remove most of them by
switching to a slimmer base
image, such as Alpine Linux.
And since we're
using Alpine, we'll
have to change our docker
file to manually include
the specific libraries we need.
But other than that, the docker
file is pretty much the same.
With just these two
fixes, we're down to zero
known vulnerabilities.
Google Container Registry's
vulnerability scanning
showed us how to
improve our security.
But those changes
came with a cost.
Because we switched from
ImageMagick to Pillow,
the app is slower and uses
more memory than before.
But for us, this was a trade-off
we were willing to make.
Eliminating over 600
bugs in a few minutes?
Yeah, that seems like a win.
Add A Cat To That
has to be secure.
Good thing we found
out about these issues
before we had an incident.
But I vaguely remember
making a last minute
check-in last night.
Hm.
I'm Carter Morgan.
And in the next video, we'll
use Cloud Security Scanner
to check for any silly mistakes
that might have been introduced
into the code base by someone--
I don't know who--
gremlins.
[MUSIC PLAYING]